Die Finanzwelt befindet sich im stetigen Wandel.
Mit der fortschreitenden Digitalisierung
im 21 Jahrhundert hat sich dieser Prozess rasant
beschleunigt und neue Möglichkeiten eröffnet,
Finanzen anders zu denken.
Digitale Währungen wie Bitcoin und Co erschüttern
positiv und negativ die Welt.
Mit dem Konzept der “Tokenisierung” wird ein neues Kapitel
in der Geschichte der Kapitalanlage aufgeschlagen.
Dezentral, demokratisch, kontrollierbar, nonstop.
Das sind die Versprechen der Tokenisierung.
Aber was sind Token überhaupt und wie funktionieren sie?
Moconomy wirft einen Blick in die komplexe Welt.
Der Token, durchleuchtet Theorie und Praxis,
spricht mit Expertinnen aus der Krypto und Fintech Szene.
Schon vor etwa 5000 Jahren betrieben
die Menschen Handel durch den Tausch
von Waren oder Dienstleistungen.
Im Laufe der Zeit entwickelten
sich Möglichkeiten, auch Anteile an Waren
oder Dienstleistungen zu handeln
und sogar an die Öffentlichkeit zu verkaufen,
um Kapital zu beschaffen.
So entstanden die Aktienmärkte,
wo Unternehmen einzelne kleine Unternehmensanteile
einer Vielzahl von Investoren anbieten,
um in die Zukunft des Unternehmens zu investieren.
Dieser Bedarf an Anteilisierung hat immer mehr zugenommen und sich letztlich
zu einem weltweiten Finanzmarkt entwickelt.
Die Tokenisierung deckt
diesen Bedarf in einer noch extremeren Art und Weise.
Denn hierbei handelt es sich um eine weitere Segmentierung
einer Einheit oder eines Bestandteil
in weitere einzelne Bestandteile.
Eine Art Bruchteilisierung.
So können beispielsweise auch Aktien
weiter brutalisiert werden
und die so entstehenden Einheiten ihrerseits gehandelt
werden.
Das Besondere und Neue an der Tokenisierung ist dabei nicht die Segmentierung,
sondern dessen Verknüpfung
mit einem weiteren Prozess der Tokenisierung.
Erst interessant macht
Die digitale und dezentrale Speicherung
der Bruchteile auf einer Blockchain.
Einzelne Sektoren des Marktes, für Tokenisierte Vermögenswerte
befinden sich zurzeit noch in einer Art
Findungs- oder Experimentierphase.
Sein Wert wird auf weniger als 20 Milliarden
US Dollar geschätzt.
Dabei beläuft sich der Wert des gesamten Marktes
für digitale Vermögenswerte auf etwa 350 Milliarden
US Dollar.
Hier wird das enorme Wachstumspotenzial deutlich.
Die Tokenisierung und die Blockchain Technologie
könnten den Finanz und Bankensektor grundlegend verändern.
Bis 2027 wird sich dieses Wachstum dramatisch
auf schätzungsweise 6,89 MilliardenDollar erhöhen.
Fintech ist einer der größten Akteure,
die das digitale Token Game aufmischen werden.
Im Jahr 2022 haben
die Vereinigten Staaten den größten Marktanteil gehalten.
Aber was ist eigentlich Tokenisierung?
Wie agieren all diese neue Token
basierten Akteure auf dem Fintech Markt?
Was ist ihre Agenda und was sind ihre Produkte?
In Europa ist Tokeny Solutions
mit Sitz in Luxemburg
einer der Marktführer
bei der Bereitstellung einer institutionellen
und modularen End to End Plattform,
die die Ausgabe, den Transfer und die Verwaltung
von handelbaren digitalen Vermögenswerten,
also Sicherheitstoken ermöglicht,
wie zum Beispiel Tokenisierte Darlehen,
strukturierte Schuldverschreibungen, Aktien und Fonds.
Dieses private B2B Unternehmen
bietet eine Plattform für die einheitliche Ausgabe
Verwaltung und den Handel
von Dienstleistungs und Sicherheitstoken.
Die Unternehmensbewertung für Tokeny Solutions
liegt zwischen 22 und 33 Millionen US Dollar
mit einer Umsatz Schätzung von 6,5 Millionen
US Dollar für das Jahr
und einem Fonds von 11 Millionen US dollar.
Das Unternehmen nutzt die Blockchain Technologie
von Ethereum und Polygon und arbeitet mit dem ERC
36 43 Token STANDARD.
Ein weiterer interessanter Player auf dem europäischen Markt
ist das in Berlin ansässige Unternehmen BitBond.
Sie haben das erste Wertpapier
Token Angebot in Europa eingeführt,
welches 2019 von der deutschen
Finanzaufsicht BaFin genehmigt worden ist.
BitBond ist ein Technologie Anbieter für Tokenisierte
Infrastruktur digitaler Assets.
Ihr Produkt Token Tool ermöglicht Ihren Kunden
die Erstellung,
Verwaltung und Verteilung von Token
und NFT über EVM Ketten.
Der BitBond Token oder
BB-One ist ein Security Bond Token,
der mit Bitcoin, Ethereum,
Stellar oder Euro gekauft werden kann.
Der Wert pro Token entspricht einem Euro.
Ihr globaler Marktanteil beträgt
aktuell weniger als 0,1%,
wird aber mit einer Teamgröße von weniger als 50 Personen
als Unternehmen mit circa
7 bis 11 Millionen US Dollar bewertet.
BitBond ist ein privates Unternehmen
mit einem Kapital von 13,2 MillionenDollar.
Sein Umsatz wird 2023
bei ungefähr einer Million US Dollar liegen.
Aber wie funktioniert das genau?
BitBond verwendet den ERC-20 Token STANDARD.
Dies ist in der Fintech Branche
der am häufigsten verwendete Sicherheits Token.
Der Token steht für tokenisierte Vermögenswerte,
die den geltenden Vorschriften für Wertpapiere entsprechen.
Es sind Wertpapiere in Form eines Token
und über ein Unternehmen wie BitBond oder Tokeny Solutions
kann der Käufer ein solches Wertpapier als Token kaufen
und handeln.
Der erworbene Token wird auf einer Blockchain implementiert.
Die Blockchains heißen Ethereum oder Polygon.
Ich bin Radoslav Albrecht
Gründer und Geschäftsführer von BitBond.
Ein Token ist ein Begriff,
den es schon lange gibt,
und er steht im Grunde dafür, dass ein Gegenstand
oder ein digitales Gut für etwas anderes steht.
Wenn man zum Beispiel auf eine Kirmes geht und Eintritt
bezahlt, bekommt man häufig einen Token, einen Plastik
Chip, den man dann im Karussell zum Beispiel abgibt.
Und da kommt der Begriff ursprünglich her.
Mein Name ist Markus Kluge, ich bin einer
der Gründer von Tokenforge.
Am bekanntesten ist der ERC-20 STANDARD,
der im Prinzip tatsächlich einfach nur ein kleines Register
ist, in dem jeder Zugriff erhält,
der dort ein Token geminted bekommen hat
und mit seinem Private
Key der einzige ist, der ihn bewegen kann.
Das ist das, was man so in der Tokenisierung
Blockchain so versteht.
Und das ist das, was halt eben ohne Regulierungen
und ohne Zugriff von von irgendeinem Administrator
oder von irgendeiner regulierten Partei
einfach mit dem hohen Risiko passiert,
dass wenn du deinen Private Key verlierst,
du auch auf diesen Token nicht mehr zugreifen kannst
und ihn auch nicht mehr bewegen
kannst, du nicht mehr verkaufen kannst.
Aus technischer Sicht ist ein Token
im Grunde ein Datenbank Eintrag und dort steht drin,
welche Adresse
Das ist im Grunde der digitale Ort,
an dem ein Token abgelegt ist.
Wie viele Stücke, wie viele Tokens hat und implementiert
wird das Ganze durch sogenannten Programmcode,
der im Kontext von Blockchains
auch Smart Contracts genannt wird, also smarte Verträge.
Aber im Grunde ist das erst mal Programmcode,
der beschreibt
Was sind die technischen Eigenschaften des Tokens
und wem gehört der Token und wer hält diese Tokens?
Wichtig bei der Tokenisierung,
also bei der Erschaffung von Datenbank
Einträgen, mit den bestimmte Rechte
der Token Eigentümer verknüpft sind,
ist also, dass es ein Register gibt, eine Datenbank,
wo die Einträge nachlesbar und sicher verwahrt werden.
Dieses Register gewährt der soeben erwähnte ERC 20 STANDARD.
Es liegt auf einer Blockchain, damit es sicher ist.
Der Token steht für einen Wert oder für eine Dienstleistung.
Token, so wie wir sie heute im FinTech Bereich verstehen,
gibt es circa seit dem Jahr 2014/2015.
Da ist die sogenannte Ethereum Blockchain entstanden
und die Ethereum Blockchain war die erste Blockchain, auf der man
Tokens, nämlich digitale Wertgegenstände, erstellen konnte.
Und so hat dann die ganze Entwicklung begonnen,
dass es digitale Tokens gab
und seitdem existiert dieser Begriff im Kontext von Fintech.
Und jetzt haben wir eben die Blockchain Technologie,
mit der mit der Kryptographie und der Signatur,
die eben eine ganze Menge mehr an an Eigenverantwortung
möglich machen, weil jeder in
dem Spiel kann halt eben sehen,
Hey, das ist wirklich derjenige, der dem das Asset gehört,
der es transferiert, das dafür sorgt eben
dieses private Key public Key
Peer, das dann eben diese Sache sicher macht.
Kryptowährungen sind auch Token.
Sie werden von Unternehmen oder Institutionen hergestellt
und verwaltet.
Streng genommen sind Kryptowährungen keine Währungen.
Es sind digitale Werte,
die getauscht und gehandelt werden können.
Ihre Erschaffung erfolgt durch sogenannte ICOs.
Der Kurz Begriff für “initial coin offerings”.
Also der erste, das erste sogenannte Initial Coin Offering,
war das von Ethereum selbst.
Und die haben im Grunde
das technische Konzept des Tokens erfunden
und haben angefangen, das zu kommerzialisieren.
Und dann kamen viele, viele weitere Firmen,
die sich diese technischen Möglichkeiten
zunutze gemacht haben
und weitere Tokens emittiert haben.
Mein Name ist Ervin Volodar
ich bin politischer Leiter
der europäischen Blockchain Association.
Wenn Sie der Meinung sind,
dass Krypto politisiert ist, stimme ich dem zu.
Seit der Entstehung des Genesis Blocks ist es politisch,
denn im Genesis Block,
also im ersten Block der Bitcoin
Blockchain,
wird auf das Versagen des Finanzsystems hingewiesen
und Bitcoin als zweite Rettungsaktion für Banken bezeichnet.
Und das war während des Höhepunkt
der Finanzkrise im Jahr 2000.
Sie können sich den Genesis Block also
als eine Art Streikposten vorstellen.
Es war ein Protest gegen das, was viele Menschen
als finanzielle Ungerechtigkeit ansahen,
die auf Kosten der Menschen zum Nutzen
einer Minderheit entstanden war.
Mit der Tokenisierung und Kryptowährung
wird ein neues Kapitel in der Geschichte
der Kapitalanlage geschrieben.
Die neue Art zu investieren, beeinflusst
Gesellschaft, Politik und Märkte.
Das revolutionäre Konzept
ermöglicht es, Vermögenswerte
in beliebig kleine Teile aufzuteilen.
Die Idee ist nicht neu.
Bruchteilseigentum ist ein beständiger Trend
unter den Finanzinstrumenten.
Schon seit Jahrhunderten werden Unternehmen
durch Aktien oder Fonds in kleine Teile zerlegt.
Gänzlich neu ist es dagegen,
diese Bruchteile als digitale Token
auf einer Blockchain zu registrieren.
Aus einer technischen Sicht gibt es circa
drei dominierende technische Standards.
Es gibt noch viele mehr.
Aber diese drei technischen Standards,
mit denen kann man alle Anwendungsfälle abbilden.
Die Tokens, die dann von Unternehmen,
die sich der Technologie zunutze machen, emittieren.
Da gibt es Tausende, wahrscheinlich gibt es um die
5 Millionen verschiedenen Token im Moment, die aber alle
die gleichen technischen Standards zugrunde haben.
Aber wo andere Werte damit repräsentiert werden.
Beispielsweise gibt es sogenannte Stable Coins,
die repräsentieren Fiat Währungen wie den Euro, den Dollar.
Dann gibt es Tokens, die zum Beispiel
Wertpapiere repräsentieren, wie Anleihen oder Aktien.
Die Tokenisierung ermöglicht die Übertragung von Werten
über ein technisches Medium,
das viele unterschiedliche Hemmnisse beseitigen kann.
Dies führt zu Kosteneinsparungen.
Durch die sofortige Abwicklung von Anteilen
eröffnen sich neue Anwendungsfälle,
wie zum Beispiel Modelle zur Nutzung von Dokumenten,
Transaktionen und darüber hinaus die Möglichkeit,
reale Vermögenswerte in digitalisierter Form darzustellen
und diese den Anlegern von Finanzprodukten anzubieten.
Man kann Schwierigkeiten
im grenzüberschreitenden Zahlungsverkehr verringern,
indem man komplexe Prozesse in kleinere Teile auf gliedert.
Das ist gerade aus institutioneller Sicht von Bedeutung.
Es ist wichtig zu erwähnen,
dass die Tokenisierung innerhalb der Blockchain
ein höheres Maß an
finanzieller Handlungsfähigkeit
und finanzieller Inklusion ermöglicht.
Meiner Meinung nach ist das von größter Wichtigkeit,
denn darum geht es doch letztlich im Kern.
Sämtliche Vermögenswerte
können so digitalisiert und standardisiert werden.
Dies erhöht die Liquidität und Transparenz.
Wie nie zuvor.
Können Prozesse so automatisiert werden.
Softwareentwickler haben sich Gedanken gemacht,
wie man Tokens standardisieren kann.
Das hat einen sehr, sehr wichtigen Hintergrund,
nämlich die Tokens werden in sogenannten Wallets gehalten.
Das sind im Grunde digitale Brieftaschen
und nicht jede Wallet
kann jede Art von Token verwahren.
Und deswegen hat man gesagt, wir etablieren einen STANDARD,
so dass im Grunde alle Wallets möglichst
viele Arten von Tokens verwahren können.
Und da haben Entwickler Vorschläge gemacht,
dass es im Endeffekt Open Source Software
und irgendwann hat der Markt bestimmte
technische Standards präferiert, weil man gesagt hat, Ja,
die funktionieren sehr, sehr gut.
Und dann haben die sich verbreitet.
Und mittlerweile gibt es mit dem sogenannten ERC
20 STANDARD für von Fungible Token
und dem sogenannten ERC 721 STANDARD für die Non Fungible Token
zwei sehr, sehr dominante Token
Standards, die kaum noch wegzudenken sind.
Und das waren einfach Ideen
von Entwicklern, die sich durchgesetzt haben
und die jetzt weltweit sehr, sehr intensiv genutzt werden.
Doch der wahre Clou der Tokenisierung
sind die mit den kleinen Teilen
einhergehenden geringen Einstieg.
Preise für Investoren.
Eine Herausforderung, der sich Blockchain,
Kryptowährungen und andere Kryptowährungen
im dezentralen Finanzwesen stellen
müssen, ist die Nutzer Erfahrung.
Die Nutzung dieser Finanzprodukte
und Dienstleistungen kann oft komplex und anspruchsvoll sein
oder erfordert ein gewisses Maß an technischem Verständnis,
das nicht jeder besitzt.
Am Ende spielt auch das persönliche Interesse eine Rolle.
Ich denke nicht, dass man sagen kann,
dass jeder diese immer und überall nutzen wird,
denn das trifft heutzutage auf alles zu.
Warum sollte es jetzt anders sein?
Die menschliche Natur ist wankelmütig.
Daher denke ich, dass es darum gehen sollte,
die Nutzung so einfach, reibungslos
und nahtlos wie möglich zu gestalten.
Auch die Emittenten sparen bares Geld.
Die Tokenisierung ermöglicht es Ihnen, einfacher
und ohne einen Vermittler an finanzielle Mittel zu kommen.
Die hohen Gebühren
für die Zusammenarbeit mit Investmentbanken
oder anderen Institutionen entfallen.
Ich bin Elizaveta Plaznik.
Ich unterstütze Krypto Asset Dienstleister, Anwaltskanzleien
und Beratungsunternehmen dabei,
sich innerhalb der neuen europäischen Regulierungen
im Bereich Crypto Asset, genannt
Mica Markets im Crypto Asset zurechtzufinden.
Die Mica
ist ein EU Rechtsrahmen für Kryptowährungen und Token,
die auf digitalen Plattformen gehandelt werden.
Sie ersetzt
die individuellen Regelungen der einzelnen Länder.
Im Rahmen von MICA
liegt mein Fokus auf bestimmten Krypto Vermögenswerten
und den dazugehörigen Dienstleistungen
innerhalb der Krypto Industrie.
Im herkömmlichen Finanzsektor haben wir bislang die MiFID,
die sämtliche Finanzinstrumente abdeckt.
Nun haben wir zusätzlich die Mica,
die alle Arten von Krypto Vermögenswerten einbezieht.
Diese sind in drei große Kategorien eingeteilt,
nämlich Stable Coins Utility Token und andere Krypto
Vermögenswerte.
Mit der Verabschiedung
einer Markets in Crypto Assets,
also Mica genannten Regulierung, wurde ein
EU weit einheitliches Konzept auf die Schiene gesetzt.
Das wird zu zahlreichen
Veränderungen in der regulatorischen Landschaft
und ebenso in der Krypto Industrie führen.
Wie Sie möglicherweise wissen, hatten alle Nationen hier
eine eigene Vorgehensweise
oder manchmal bisher auch überhaupt keine.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass sich dadurch viele Veränderungen ergeben werden,
auch im Finanzsektor. Warum?
Wenn Sie heute zu Ihrer Bank gehen
und sagen, Sie möchten gerne
Bitcoin kaufen, wird diese Anfrage
höchstwahrscheinlich abgelehnt.
Einige werden sich darauf einlassen,
aber 99% werden sagen Nein, das machen wir nicht.
Seit dem Inkrafttreten von Mica
können Sie diese Dienstleistungen nun vermehrt nutzen,
vorausgesetzt, Sie vertrauen Ihrer Bank oder Ihrem Broker
und er oder sie verfügt über das nötige
Wissen und die nötige Erfahrung.
Die Kryptowährungen
werden über Krypto Börsen gehandelt.
Utility Token repräsentieren einen bestimmten Nutzen
oder eine bestimmte Funktionalität auf einer Plattform.
Es gibt verschiedene Arten von Token,
die als Finanzinstrumente dienen können.
Security Token fungieren als digitale Wertpapiere.
Sie können die Eigenschaften von Aktien oder Anleihen haben.
Ein Security Token ist ein Token,
der normalerweise ein Wertpapier verbrieft,
und aus technischer Sicht nennt man dort häufig, den ERC 20 Token
der ein Fungibler Token ist
Aber mit einigen Ergänzungen,
zum Beispiel ist es bei Wertpapieren häufig
wichtig zu wissen, wer hält diese Token
und dort gibt es bestimmte technische Einstellungen,
die man vornehmen kann,
damit diese Token nicht überallhin verschickt werden können,
sondern nur an bestimmte Empfänger,
die auf einer sogenannten Whitelist sind.
Das bedeutet, man hat freigegeben, welche Empfänger
diesen Token halten dürfen.
Und Security Token werden technisch eben
häufig so ausgestaltet, weil die Emittenten diejenigen,
die diese Token herausgeben, häufig wissen möchten
oder auch teilweise gesetzlich wissen müssen,
wer diese Token hält.
Dann gibt es Tokens,
die als Utility Token bezeichnet werden.
Das sind häufig Plattformen, spezifische Währungen.
Das kann man sich so vorstellen,
dass beispielsweise auf sozialen Medien
nicht mit normalem Geld bezahlt wird,
sondern mit einem Token, der speziell
für diese Plattformen erstellt wurde.
Und dafür kann man dann
bestimmte Dinge auf dieser Plattform nutzen.
Der Prozess der Tokenisierung beginnt
mit der Erfassung von Informationen über den Vermögenswert.
Dies kann beispielsweise eine detaillierte Beschreibung
einer Immobilie sein oder eine Liste der Kunstwerke
in einer Sammlung mit all ihren individuellen Eigenschaften.
Diese Informationen werden dann in eine digitale Form
konvertiert und gespeichert.
Anschließend wird ein Token generiert,
der die Eigentumsrechte
an dem beschriebenen Sachwert repräsentiert.
Der Token wird ebenfalls auf der Blockchain gespeichert
und enthält dank der individuellen Information
einen eindeutigen digitalen Fingerabdruck des Vermögenswert.
Es gibt eine ganze Menge Widerstand, einfach weil
weil es eine neue Technologie ist
und auch ein Paradigmenwechsel in der Herangehensweise.
Wenn man früher irgendwie
etwas von A nach B bewegt hat, also ein Wertpapier.
Deswegen wurden die Wertpapiere als solche auch gemacht,
dann hat man sie wirklich von A nach B bewegt.
Und jetzt hast du einen Gedanken, der einfach sagt
ich ändere das Zugriffsrecht auf diese, auf diesen Token.
Und indem ich den transferiert, das heißt das
Wertpapier, klebt es an dem Asset
und ist nicht mehr ein frei bewegliches Wertpapier.
Und das hat eine ganze Menge Implikationen in den Prozessen.
Und es ist jetzt einfach unsere Aufgabe,
dass wir in der Lage sind, all die Technologien,
all die Möglichkeiten, die man jetzt zusammenstecken kann,
also digitale Identitäten, digitale Währungen
und eben die Tokenisierung so zusammenstecken,
dass der Zugriff eben wirklich demokratisiert wird.
Sobald ein Token erstellt
und auf einer Blockchain gespeichert wurde,
kann er durch Smart Contracts verwaltet werden.
Über Smart Contracts können
Mietzahlungen anteilig
an einen Investor transferiert werden,
sobald die Miete eingegangen ist,
oder er veranlasst automatisch Zahlungen,
sobald bestimmte Meilensteine
in einem Projekt erreicht werden.
Das Faszinierende an Token ist,
dass es sich im Grunde um programmierbare Werte handelt,
die auf einer Blockchain registriert sind.
Ich möchte hier nicht von Geld sprechen,
weil es einen Unterschied
zwischen Geld und seiner regulierten
und übertragbaren Werte gibt.
Aber es ist wichtig, wenn wir zum Beispiel
über Nachhaltigkeit nachdenken,
dass wir nicht nur einen neuen digitalen Vermögenswert
einführen,
sondern auch damit ein bestimmtes Signal setzen.
Wir müssen ihm also eine Bedeutung verleihen,
die einen bestimmten Wert entspricht.
Und das wird, denke ich, der wichtigste Aspekt
der Tokenisierung sein
dass wir sowohl digitale Maßstäbe setzen
als auch seine Nutzung optimieren
und Anreize für bestimmte Praktiken schaffen können.
Das Investieren in Tokenisierte
Immobilien ist eine der neuesten Entwicklungen
in der Immobilienbranche.
Die Tokenisierung macht es möglich,
dass Häuser und Wohnungen nicht nur als einzelne Einheiten,
sondern beliebig kleinteilig,
segmentiert und gehandelt werden können.
Hier sind es kleine Programme, die als technische Brücke
zwischen der Immobilie und einer
Online Verkaufs Plattform dienen.
Token schaffen ein digitales Abbild einer Immobilie
und machen sie so digital handelbar.
Problem ist dabei, dass viele Anleger
dementsprechend entweder nicht
in der Größenordnung einsteigen möchten.
In diesem Markt oder nicht einsteigen können,
weil ihnen beispielsweise das Eigenkapital fehlt
oder sie keine Fremdfinanzierung bekommen.
Und die Idee und der große Vorteil
der Tokenisierung ist jetzt diese kleinste Einheit,
die erwerbbar ist,
sehr viel kleiner zu machen.
Ein Wohnungsbesitzer kann beispielsweise eine Wohnung,
die einen Wert von 100.000€ hat, in 1000 Token zerlegen.
Jeder Token hat dann einen Wert von 100€
und repräsentiert einen winzigen Prozentsatz der Immobilie.
Mit jedem Token
erwerben die Anleger das Recht
auf einen bestimmten Prozentsatz der Mieteinnahmen.
Davon werden Kosten wie die Grundsteuer,
Reparaturen oder Versicherungen abgezogen.
Wenn die Wohnung mit der Zeit an Wert gewinnt
und auch die Mieteinnahmen steigen,
steigt auch der Wert des Tokens.
Ein weiterer Vorteil der Tokenisierung
ist die jederzeitige Handelbarkeit der einzelnen Token.
Letzten Endes 24/7 über Apps oder Handelsplattformen.
Und man muss eben nicht mehr zum Notar gehen
und dort eine Beurkundung stattfinden
lassen, um eine Immobilie bzw
einen Anteil an einer Immobilie zu erwerben.
Der Erwerber verwaltet seine Token
ganz einfach mithilfe einer Wallet App.
Je nach Ausgestaltung der App
kann man nicht nur Zahlungseingang überprüfen
oder sich die Wert Veränderungen
seiner Token als Diagramm ausgeben lassen,
sondern die Token sogar direkt
über das Smartphone wieder verkaufen.
Immobilien Token werden derzeit wie Wertpapiere behandelt.
Käufer besitzen
insofern keinen physischen Anteil an einer Immobilie.
Ein Immobilien Token ist im Prinzip ein Darlehen,
das der Anbieter der Token zur Finanzierung
der Immobilie nutzt.
Die Zinsen für dieses Darlehen
werden aus den Mieteinnahmen gezahlt.
Das birgt ein gewisses Verlustrisiko.
Es drohen Miet, Ausfälle und schlimmstenfalls sogar
die Insolvenz des Anbieters.
Dieses Risiko ist insofern höher
als bei einem Immobilienfonds, über den man in der Regel
in viele Immobilien gleichzeitig investiert.
In Deutschland ist ein solches Szenario
allerdings noch Zukunftsmusik,
weil es hier derzeit noch
an einem regulatorischen Rahmen fehlt,
der eine derartig Verbriefung
von Eigentumsrechten an Grundstücken
und Immobilien möglich machen würde.
Die Prozesse, die mit einem Immobilienkauf
einhergehen, bleiben daher vorerst noch mit viel Bürokratie,
Zeitaufwand und damit auch hohen Kosten verbunden.
Wirklich bekannt
wurde die Organisierung aber durch digitale Kunstprojekte.
Mithilfe von None Fungible Tokens
können einzigartige digitale Güter dargestellt
werden.
Der amerikanische Künstler Beeple versteigerte im März 2021
eine digitale Collage aus 5000 Einzelbildern
für beispiellose 69,5 Millionen US Dollar.
Twitter Gründer Jack Dorsey ist erster Tweet bei einem Fan
Satte 2,9 Millionen US Dollar wert.
Mein Name ist Everfresh
auch bekannt als Sebastian Pfeifer.
So etwas wie im Jahr 2021 werden wir nicht mehr sehen.
Das Schiff ist bereits abgefahren.
Ich hoffe jedoch,
dass der Kunstmarkt noch etwas erwachsener
wird, damit Künstler
vernünftige Preise für ihre digitalen Werke erzielen
und auch davon leben können.
Nicht jeder
Künstler wird das schaffen.
Aber darum geht es auch nicht.
So funktioniert der Markt eben nicht.
Es schaffen nur wenige.
Man sieht eine ständig steigende Anzahl
der Leute, die Krypto Kunst sammeln.
Ich heiße Sergio Roberto Schmoldt
und bin der Gründer und CEO von MAGALL
MAGALL steht für Meter Art Gallery.
Im Januar 2021 gab es eine Blase,
bei der der Krypto Kunstmarkt NFT um 14.000% anstieg.
Allerdings fällt man nach einem solchen Höhenflug
auch sehr schnell wieder.
Wir versuchen im Moment ein sinnvolles Niveau zu erreichen,
von dem aus wir gemeinsam mit Krypto, Bitcoin
und allem, was dazu gehört, wachsen können.
Kunst Tokens können von überall auf der Welt gekauft werden.
Das ermöglicht globale Investitionen in Kunst.
Twitter ist die beste Plattform,
um seine Werke innerhalb der NFT-Welt bekannt zu machen.
Es gibt zwar auch andere Social Media Plattformen,
aber Twitter ist eindeutig die effektivste.
Ich erreiche mein Publikum vor allem über Twitter.
Natürlich veröffentliche
ich meine Werke auch auf anderen Plattformen,
aber bisher habe ich keine vergleichbaren Verkäufe
durch andere Plattformen.
Derzeit liegt der größte Trend
darin, Dinge aus dem Metavers ins reale Leben zu bringen.
Man kann Krypto Kunst nur wirklich wahrnehmen,
wenn man sie sehen und berühren kann.
Ähnlich wie hier auf unseren Bildschirmen.
Diesen Weg sollten Galeristen einschlagen.
Nichts zu tun.
Mit Hilfe der Non Fungible Token
werden digitale Kunstgegenstände in der Regel
als Ganzes in der Blockchain verbrieft.
Selbst wenn ein Künstler mehrere NFTs des exakt
gleichen Bildes generiert,
hat jeder Einzelne eine einzigartige Identität
in der Blockchain.
Und das bedeutet,
dass Token, die im Grunde eineindeutig sind.
Wir können uns das
so ein bisschen in der realen Welt vorstellen,
Wenn wir eine Euro Münze in der Hand halten,
dann ist es uns egal, ob wir die eine
oder die andere Euro Münze haben.
Weil sie sind in ihrer Kaufkraft absolut identisch
und wir unterscheiden das nicht.
Das wären sogenannte Fungible Tokens.
Und das gleiche trifft auch auf Wertpapiere zu.
Wenn ich eine BMW Aktie habe,
ist es mir egal, ob ich die eine oder die andere
BMW Aktie habe.
Die BMW Aktie verbrieft das gleiche Recht.
Ich habe das gleiche Stimmrecht und den gleichen Wert
bei NFTs den sogenannten None Fungible Token.
Die kann man mit Kunstwerken vergleichen.
Wenn ich beispielsweise ein Picasso
Bild oder die Mona Lisa besitzen würde,
dann ist diese eineindeutig.
Es Mag Fälschungen geben, aber die echte Mona
Lisa gibt es nur einmal.
Die ist nicht Fungible
sondern es gibt eben nur diese eine.
Und jedes andere Bild ist wieder anders.
Es gibt auch das Konzept der Drucke
in der Kunst, wo zum Beispiel ein Foto Druck
eine limitierte Auflage hat, 100 Stück beispielsweise.
Und jedes einzelne Foto hat dann eine Nummer.
Und es gibt eben diese Serie auch
so kann man None Fungible Tokens verwenden.
Aber es ist immer so gedacht,
dass jeder Token eineindeutig identifizierbar ist,
während bei den Fungiblen Wertpapier
Token alle Tokens identisch und austauschbar sind.
Es existieren gewisse
Grauzonen im Zusammenhang mit NFT.
Vieles existiert unter dem Oberbegriff DeFi.
aber grundsätzlich fallen NFT nicht unter DeFi
sondern werden durch die Mica geregelt.
Wenn etwas in Serie
oder einer großen Auflage ausgegeben wird,
ist das ein Indikator für Austauschbarkeit
und somit kein NFT
Aber was bedeutet große Auflage?
Wie wird diese definiert?
Und wir hoffen, dass wir diese Grauzonen
mit der Zeit abschaffen werden.
Wir bemühen uns, diese Begrifflichkeiten
in Zukunft klar zu definieren, auch wenn es schwierig wird,
da die technologische Entwicklung so rasant ist.
Die meisten NFT Verkäufe sind eigentlich Auktionen.
Es sind keine klassischen Auktionen,
bei denen ein Mann mit einem Hammer erscheint.
Normalerweise stellt man sein Objekt auf einer Plattform
zu einem Mindestpreis zur Verfügung.
Danach kann man die Dauer der Auktion
mittels eines Timers festlegen.
Üblicherweise dauert diese 24 Stunden.
Wie lange sie tatsächlich dauert, hängt davon ab,
ob andere Personen auch Gebote abgeben,
ob der Preis steigt oder nicht.
Die meisten Plattformen verlangen
eine Gebühr von 5 bis 15%.
Es gibt auch einige, die verlangen 20%.
Aber der Großteil liegt bei 15%.
die Tokenisierung kann so zu einem wichtigen Instrument
werden, um Kunst für ein breites Publikum zugänglich
zu machen.
Investitionen in Kunst werden
so einfach, sicher und zuverlässig.
Auch für die Künstler selbst könnte die Tokenisierung
ein spannendes Vehikel für den Verkauf ihrer Werke sein.
Theoretisch kann der Künstler sich sogar selbst
den Investoren als Kapitalanlage anbieten.
Steigt sein Wert, profitieren die Anleger.
Auf der anderen Seite generiert der Künstler
ein regelmäßiges Zusatzeinkommen.
Der Kunstmarkt ist nach wie vor
noch verhältnismäßig intransparent
und deswegen braucht man eben tiefe Kenntnisse
von den Playern, den Einflussfaktoren,
den Dynamiken an diesem Markt,
um kompetitiv unterwegs sein zu können.
Wenn man Kunstwerke kauft.
Die Arbeiten, die wir im Portfolio haben,
die Top 100 Künstlerinnen und Künstler,
die findet man eben nicht beim Wald
und Wiesen Galeristen um die Ecke, sondern in der Regel
bei den international führenden Galerien.
Und wenn man diese Zugänge nicht hat,
dann kommt man entweder gar nicht an die Kunstwerke
oder zu sehr überteuerten Preisen,
weil die Kunstwerke dann eben schon
mehrere Handels Schritte durchlaufen haben
und jeder Handelsschrit
wird mit mit einer Verteuerung einhergehen.
Bruchteilseigentum an einem Vermögenswert
wird im Bereich der Kunst über sogenannte Art Security
Tokens oder ASTs abgebildet.
Das sind digitale Vermögenswerte,
die einem Teil an einem Kunstwerk entsprechen.
Dieser Markt war bisher allerdings
nur sehr, sehr wohlhabenden Menschen zugänglich,
allein schon aufgrund der hohen Kaufpreise,
die diese Kunstwerke haben.
Da reden wir von sechs siebenstelligen Beträgen,
teilweise drüber.
Und die wenigsten Menschen haben das Geld, um sich
diese Kunst leisten zu können.
Und wir ändern das.
Art Trade kümmert sich um
die Kunstwerke, das heißt wir unterhalten
ein Netzwerk von Kunstexperten, mit denen wir
attraktive Werke identifizieren.
Das Ganze wird quer geschnitten
mit einem sehr aufwendigen Datenanalyse Prozess
und die Kunstwerke, wenn wir dann eins identifiziert haben,
dann fraktionalisieren, wir sie sozusagen digital wir geben
pro Kunstwerk
ein digitales Wertpapier aus, in Form von sogenannten
Security Token.
1€ Emissionswerte des Kunstwerkes
entspricht dabei einem Token. Der Security Token, den wir ausgeben.
Das ist letztlich ein digitales Wertpapier, voll reguliert
nach EWPG, nach den neuen elektronischen Wertpapier Gesetz.
Das enthält auch eine ISIN.
Und das ermöglicht es uns, eben
diesen Token und das Wertpapier zu behandeln,
wie andere klassische Wertpapiere auch
und sie letztlich in die Infrastruktur
der Finanzindustrie zu integrieren.
Mit Ihrer Hilfe kann nun jeder in Kunstwerke investieren,
die es unter normalen Umständen niemals in das Anlage
Portfolio des Durchschnitts Anlegers schaffen würden.
Man kann bereits ab 1.000€ mittelbar
in diese Kunstwerke investieren, indem man diese Token kauft
und so an der Wertentwicklung der Kunstwerke partizipiert.
Und dadurch sorgen wir dafür,
dass man schon mit kleineren Beträgen an ganz großer Kunst
teilhaben kann.
Selbst die alten Meister finden sich inzwischen
auf der Blockchain.
Erst vor kurzem wurde Pablo Picassos Meisterwerk
Fillette au beret auf einer Blockchain Tokenisiert.
Verantwortlich ist eine in Zürich ansässige Krypto Bank,
die das Ölgemälde in 4000 der Kunsttoken zerlegte
und diese für jeweils 1000 Schweizer Franken verkaufte.
Dafür wurden die Token wiederum
in Blockchain basierte Wertpapiere umgewandelt,
die in der Schweiz einen unstrittigen Rechtsanspruch
auf das einzigartige Gemälde von 1964 darstellen.
Als Anlegerin oder Anleger
hat man letztlich am Ende nicht ein Stück des Kunstwerkes,
sondern einen verbrieften Anspruch, an der Wertentwicklung
dieses Kunstwerkes zu partizipieren.
Wir haben uns bewusst
gegen Bruchteilseigentum entschieden
und für ein Wertpapier,
weil es dann letztlich einem,
ja einem klassischen Investment Produkt entspricht
und auch im Finanzsystem entsprechend integriert werden
kann.
Bei Arbeiten, die auf dem Sekundärmarkt gehandelt
werden, heißt, wo es schon
ein Käufer gab und die werden dann weiter gehandelt. Da
patizipiert der Künstler
oder die Künstlerin in der Regel nicht mehr dran.
Perspektivisch ist das aber schon ein Modell,
was wir ausbauen wollen,
Denn es gibt die Möglichkeit, in die Token, in die Smart
Contracts eben auch hinein zur strukturieren.
Dass der Künstler über einen gewissen Prozentsatz
an der Wertentwicklung des Kunstwerkes
auch dauerhaft beteiligt bleibt.
Aber das ist noch Zukunftsmusik.
Wenn ich mir anschaue, was meine Kinder sammeln,
Fortnite Skins oder digitale Waffen für Spiele,
dann sehe ich eine vielversprechende Zukunft voraus.
Das Sammeln von digitaler Kunst
ähnelt dieser Art des Sammelns.
Picasso oder Ölgemälde
Werden die Leute nicht mehr an die Wand hängen.
Auch meine Kinder nicht.
Sie werden andere Kunstwerke sammeln.
Auch die Finanzierung großer Kunstgalerien, Museen,
Sammlungen und Lager Einrichtungen für Kunstwerke
könnte in naher Zukunft von der Tokenisierung profitieren,
denn sie investieren Unsummen in den Schutz
ihrer Kunstgegenstände.
Diebstahl, Vandalismus.
Das zu verhindern, kostet Geld.
Geld, das die Museen nicht haben.
Diesen Institutionen fehlt es an Liquidität.
Die Eintrittsgelder und Fördertöpfe
reichen häufig nicht, um die Sammlungen zu erweitern.
Die Tokenisierung
könnte ihnen zu dieser Liquidität verhelfen.
Sie könnte die Sammlungen oder einen ausgesuchten Teil davon
für Investoren verfügbar machen,
die einen Gewinn aus der Wertsteigerung
der Kunstwerke ziehen.
Eine Aktie ist ein von
einem Unternehmen ausgegebenes Wertpapier
je nach Art der Aktie.
Kann das ein Anspruch auf einen Teil des Gewinns,
auf Dividenden oder ein Mitspracherecht sein.
Unternehmen geben Aktien aus, um zusätzliche Mittel
für ihre Geschäfts entwicklung zu beschaffen.
Doch trotz der Digitalisierung bleibt der Handel mit Aktien
an vielen Stellen ineffizient.
Wer in Aktien investieren möchte,
der muss eine ganze Aktie kaufen.
Die Aktien großer Unternehmen kosten
jedoch oftmals über 1000 US Dollar.
Das schränkt den Kreis
derer, die sich das leisten können, ein.
Und selbst wenn man sich einen Teil der großen Unternehmen
sichert, entfällt dadurch automatisch
die Möglichkeit, das Portfolio durch Investitionen
in mehrere Aktien zu diversifizieren.
Mein Name ist Phillipp Pieper.
Ich bin einer der Mitbegründer von Swarm.
Wir sind eine Plattform,
die sowohl Erstausgabe als auch Sekundär
Handel von Token anbietet.
In den letzten zwei Jahren rückten
massive Crypto Assets in den Fokus der Öffentlichkeit.
Also im Grunde Bitcoin und andere native Vermögenswerte,
die auf einer Blockchain,
wie zum Beispiel auf Ethereum basieren.
Es hat sich jedoch gezeigt,
dass zwischen all diesen Vermögenswerten
eine starke Korrelation besteht.
Wenn der Markt wächst, dann steigen auch die Preise
der Asset.
Schrumpft der Markt jedoch, fallen
die Preise oder brechen ein.
Es ist daher notwendig, dass reale Vermögenswerte
in der Kette repliziert werden,
welche ihren Wert direkt aus dem zugrunde
liegenden Vermögenswert ableiten,
der mit diesen digitalen Vermögenswert verbunden ist.
Ein gutes Beispiel hierfür ist ein sogenannter Stable Coin.
Die Tokenisierung ermöglicht es, Bruchteile der Aktien
dieser großen Unternehmen zu kaufen,
anstatt eine ganze Aktie zu kaufen.
Kann man so nur einen einer Aktie kaufen
und damit eine anteilige Rendite erwirtschaften.
Mithilfe der Tokenisierung werden
digitale Abbilder von bereits
herausgegebenen Wertpapieren geschaffen.
Man spricht von Token Derivaten.
Diese werden in der Blockchain verbrieft
und so in eine flexiblere Infrastruktur eingebettet.
So erhält man im Prinzip eine normale Aktie,
aber mit den Vorteilen von Kryptowährungen.
Der Kurs der Tokenisierten Aktie entspricht
immer dem Aktienkurs des ausgehenden Unternehmens.
Wenn sich der Wert der hinterlegten Aktie verdoppelt,
verdoppelt sich auch der Wert der Tokenisierten Aktie.
Die Kursentwicklung wird ähnlich wie bei Aktien analysiert,
nicht wie bei Kryptowährungen.
Ein Stable Coin kann im Grunde ein Token sein,
der einen Dollar repräsentiert.
Er entspricht also einem Dollar.
Dadurch haben wir die Möglichkeit, alles,
was eine Art Wert besitzt,
in die Blockchain und deren Trading Umgebung zu bringen
und sind in der Lage, diese Vermögenswerte zu fraktionieren
bzw zu digitalisieren.
Es gibt ein sehr großes Spektrum
von verschiedenen Vermögenswerten,
die man so als digitalen Vermögenswert
in die Blockchain bringen kann.
Wenn Sie eine Apple Aktie besitzen,
die durch einen Token repräsentiert wird,
warum sollen Sie dann nicht
auch einen Cent der Aktie erwerben können,
wenn Sie das möchten?
Das funktioniert nicht auf den traditionellen Finanzmärkten.
Die Tokenisierung
reduziert die Einstiegshürde an den neuen Finanzmärkten
dadurch erheblich.
Der überwiegende Teil aller Unternehmen
weltweit sind derzeit Privatunternehmen.
Es gibt ähnliche
Produkte, die einige dieser Funktionen imitieren,
aber sie bieten nicht das gleiche Maß an Flexibilität.
Zweitens erhält man die Möglichkeit
einer sofortigen Abwicklung
an einer dezentralen Börse oder einem Handelsplatz
können wir uns auf einen Preis einigen
und das Geschäft sofort über die Blockchain abwickeln.
Die Übertragung meines Eigentums
auf den bisherigen Finanzmärkten
kann bis zu zwei, drei Tage dauern.
Aus politischer Sicht besitzt
die USA auch gerade wegen des Dollars eine Sonderstellung.
Man hat einmal gesagt, der Dollar sei zwar
die Währung der Vereinigten Staaten,
aber das Problem aller anderen.
Das sehe ich nicht so,
denn ich denke, dass der Dollar
auch für die Vereinigten Staaten ein Problem darstellt.
In anderen Ländern gibt es bereits Gerichtsbarkeiten,
die im Grunde Vorschriften für den
digitalen US Dollar schaffen.
Nichts davon kommt bisher aus den USA.
Die Regulierung von Stable Coins
gehört zu den low hanging fruits.
Es wäre somit das einfachste Mittel,
um die Position des Dollars wieder zu stärken.
Und das ist nicht die Position,
die Europa im gleichen Maße vertritt.
Ich meine, der US Dollar macht immer noch etwa
60% der weltweiten Geldreserven aus.
Das politische System
der Vereinigten Staaten ist von seiner Konzeption her
eher kämpferisch für Wettbewerb konzipiert.
Und man sollte das immer bedenken,
wenn man die USA betrachtet.
Die Tokenisierten Aktien
schlagen damit eine Brücke
zwischen den traditionellen Wertpapier
Börsen wie der Xetra oder der Börse Frankfurt
und einer Krypto Börse wie Binance.
Je nach Netzwerk und Krypto Börse
können Token Transaktionen
in wenigen Minuten abgewickelt werden.
Die Möglichkeit, rund um die uhr handeln zu können,
ohne dass die Märkte still stehen,
stellt einen klaren Vorteil dar.
Das bringt den Menschen reales Geld.
Wenn man dies mit Steuerungs prozessen verknüpfen
kann, ist das ebenfalls ein Vorteil,
weil man eine viel direktere Interaktion. Hat.
Und die
Transaktionen Prozesse uneingeschränkt verfolgen kann.
Aber noch wichtiger ist das entstehende Vertrauen
auf die Daten, die mit dem Token verbunden sind.
Diese zeichnen ein Bild vom tatsächlichen Wert
und berichten mit Live Daten.
Dadurch ist man plötzlich nicht mehr
auf einen Quartalsbericht angewiesen,
sondern man hat einen Überblick in Echtzeit.
Da Smart Contracts Transaktionen von Tokenisierten
Wertpapieren auf einer Blockchain abwickeln.
Ist das Vertrauen in einen Broker oder Banker
als Vermittler nicht mehr notwendig.
Ich würde sagen, die sind im Großen und Ganzen
einige der Aspekte, in denen die Tokenisierung
die Finanzindustrie verändern wird, unabhängig davon,
ob man glaubt, dass es eine vollständige Abschaffung
der Zwischenhändler geben wird oder nicht.
Es wird sicherlich die Rolle der Finanz Vermittler einschränken
oder deren Anzahl
bei bestimmten Finanztransaktionen reduzieren.
In der Welt der Tokenisierung hat letztlich alles
einen Bezug zu einem realen Wert oder Gegenstand.
Es wird ein Vertrauensverhältnis geschaffen.
Das bedeutet, selbst wenn ein Token verloren geht,
was immer darauf ankommt,
wie Sie Ihr Investment
gestalten, man immer sicherstellen kann,
dass entweder der aktuelle Besitzer anerkannt wird
oder dass der Token
an den ursprünglichen Besitzer zurückgeht.
Also einfach eine sehr effiziente Technologie.
Der Verkauf von Unternehmensanteile ist bürokratisch,
dauert lange und es sind viele Akteure involviert.
Die technischen Möglichkeiten haben wir
und wir müssen jetzt gucken,
dass sie die beiden Extreme zusammenbringen.
Hier haben wir einmal die traditionelle Welt,
die sagt, Wir wollen das alles über Clearstream weiter abhandeln,
weil sich das einfach über die letzten Jahrzehnte einfach
als sehr stabil erwiesen hat
und natürlich auch die Stakeholder drin sind,
die ihr Geld damit verdienen.
Logischerweise.
Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir die
DeFi
und die die Crypto Welt, die sagt,
wir wollen alles in Selbstbestimmung machen.
Und wie meistens liegt die Wahrheit
wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Mitte
und das müssen wir jetzt auch entsprechend bauen.
Investoren haben zu diesen Unternehmen keinen Zugang.
Investitionen werden hauptsächlich von Finanzinstituten
in Form teurer Kredite oder Beteiligungsformen getätigt.
Der Markt verfügt daher über eine minimale Liquidität.
Ja, ich denke, es wird sich eher auf den B2B Bereich auswirken,
weil wir als Endnutzer in erster Linie
an Benutzerfreundlichkeit
und natürlich an Sicherheit interessiert sind.
Wir sind weniger daran interessiert, ob eine Bank oder
Fintech, nun Technologie A oder B verwendet.
Vor allem wenn wir über Massen Anwendungen
sprechen, dann sollten Unternehmen keine Rolle spielen.
Es muss einfach eine gut funktionierende App sein.
Wenn investiert wird, dann fast immer.
Langfristig
schlägt die Unternehmensführung eine andere Richtung ein.
Können die Investoren nicht einfach aussteigen.
Sie versuchen dann, Einfluss
auf die Unternehmensführung zu nehmen.
Die Prozesse werden träge.
Wenn man
jetzt denkt, dass es sich um ein komplett offenes Netzwerk
handelt, zu dem jeder Zugang hat,
dann ist das nicht ganz richtig.
Der Aufbau des Systems hängt sehr stark
vom Vermögenswert, der gehandelt wird.
Je nach Vermögenswert gibt es Beschränkungen,
die man natürlich im System berücksichtigen muss, damit
nur eine bestimmte Art von Kunden, die Token kaufen kann
oder man selbst konkrete Standards im Nutzerverhalten,
damit der Handel mit Token ausgeführt werden kann.
Es handelt sich also um sehr technologie
bedingte Einschränkungen,
aber es schafft auch ein viel höheres Maß an
Vertrauen in den Regulierungs Prozess.
Da es sich um einen Code handelt,
der exakt das umsetzt, was angefragt wurde
und dieser kann nicht wirklich umgangen werden.
Wir gehen davon aus,
dass die Tokenisierung und die Blockchain
Technologie eine große Rolle spielen
werden, um Prozesse effizienter und schlanker zu gestalten.
Das ist der erste Schritt.
Hinzu kommt, die Tokenisierung
und auch die Blockchain Technologie dafür zu nutzen,
um verschiedene Vermögenswerte
auf verschiedene Weise zu finanzieren und zu Tokenisieren.
Dieser Wachstums Aspekt
hängt sowohl stark von der kommenden Regulierung
als auch von den strategischen Entscheidungen einiger Neo
Blockchain Banken bzw Playern auf dem Markt ab.
Wir können davon ausgehen, dass wir in der nächsten Zeit
neue Anwendungsfälle und eine ganze Reihe
neuer Konzepte sehen werden.
Das bedeutet völlig neue Kategorien von Anwendungsfällen,
die es so noch nicht gibt.
In Diskussionen über die Zukunft der Energiewirtschaft
wird immer häufiger auf über Energy Tokenisierung gesprochen.
Wir leben in einer Zeit,
in der erneuerbare Energien extrem populär geworden sind.
Immer mehr Anleger investieren in Wind und Solarparks.
Mein Name ist Ekow
Ich bin Geschäftsführer von Relport.
Die Dezentralisierung der Energie ist bereits im Gange
und wird sich weiter beschleunigen.
Ich glaube, dass die letzten Jahre
mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine
und dem Wunsch der Regierungen unabhängiger zu werden,
einen unglaublichen Boom bei Solar Dächern
und dezentraler Energie erzeugt haben.
Mit der Entwicklung von Unternehmen
und Lieferketten wird es für Mieter
und Hausbesitzer noch einfacher
werden, Solaranlagen auf ihren Dächern zu installieren.
Und dann geht es darum, dass die verschiedenen dezentralen
Knotenpunkte miteinander verbunden werden.
Also von Dach zu Dach
und intelligent in das Stromnetz eingebunden werden.
Und ich denke, dass die Technologie dabei eine
wichtige Rolle spielen wird.
Doch das komplexe Netzwerk des Energiesektors
leidet unter einer veralteten Infrastruktur.
Hinzu kommen zahlreiche ineffiziente Prozesse.
Mithilfe der Blockchain
kann die Effizienz der Energieversorgung erhöht werden.
Und Effizienz bedeutet Kostenersparnis.
Kostenersparnis bedeutet kleinere Projekte
und somit auch, dass es nur eine überschaubare
Gruppe von Investoren braucht.
Was für viele Menschen von Vorteil ist.
Es macht vieles effizienter,
macht den Zugang effizienter
und ermöglicht auch kleineren Windparks
die Teilnahme an der Energiewirtschaft.
Durch ihre dezentrale Architektur
ist sie in der Lage, die Lieferketten
verschiedener Energieerzeuger gleichzeitig zu dokumentieren.
Bei zentralisierten Systemen ist dies deutlich aufwendiger.
Hier muss jeder Erzeuger seine Daten
zunächst an eine zentrale Stelle schicken, an der
die Daten gebündelt und aufbereitet werden können.
In einem dezentralen Blockchain Netzwerk
kann nun jeder die Daten direkt einspeisen.
Mit Hilfe der Tokenisierung kann für jede physische Energie Einheit
eine digitale Version auf einer Blockchain gespeichert
werden.
Durch diese Automatisierung der Verwaltungs
Prozesse kann Energie so deutlich billiger werden.
Auf der anderen Seite
sehen wir, dass es zwei verschiedene Formen gibt.
Eine Form besteht in der Aufteilung
der wirtschaftlichen Leistung, eines Energie Projekts
oder eines Teiles eines Projekts für erneuerbare Energien.
Also ein Erzeuger möchte einen Windpark errichten
und benötigt dazu Investoren, denen er verspricht,
dass die Einnahmen aus dem Windpark
unter den Investoren aufgeteilt werden.
Somit sind wir also in Zukunft in der Lage
Einnahmen aus dieser Investition in Token umzuwandeln
und damit dieses Projekt zu finanzieren.
Der viel schwierigere Teil ist
die Frage, wie wir erneuerbare Energien
durch nationale Agenturen zertifizieren
und in gewissem Sinne Fungibel oder handelbar machen.
Die Blockchain Technologie ermöglicht es zudem,
die Energie von der Quelle
bis zum Endverbraucher zu verfolgen.
Falls nötig, können Zertifikate ausgestellt
werden, die den Kauf belegen.
Das kann speziell bei den strengen
Regularien der erneuerbaren Energie
ein entscheidendes Kriterium sein.
Derzeit weiß im Grunde niemand, ob die Energie aus Wind,
Solar oder einer anderen Quelle stammt.
Die Herkunft muss ein Dritter bescheinigen.
Diese Zertifikate werden gehandelt.
Greenwashing wird begünstigt.
Es gibt verschiedene
rechtliche und regulatorische Aspekte,
die damit verbunden sind.
An erster Stelle steht die EU Taxonomie,
die uns vorgibt, was grün ist und was nicht.
Das ist eine Orientierungshilfe
für Investoren und Emittenten Finanzprodukten.
Zweitens gibt es eine Verordnung zur Nachhaltigkeits
bezogenen Offenlegungspflicht (SFDR).
Jeder Emittent von Finanzprodukten
muss selbst beurteilen, ob er hoch nachhaltig ist.
Artikel neun oder nicht nachhaltig Artikel sieben
Und das wird den Verbrauchern
eine enorme Orientierungshilfe sein,
welche Dienstleistungen grün sind und welche nicht.
Das bedeutet also, dass der Spielraum für Greenwashing
sehr viel kleiner wird.
Dank der Tokenisierung kann ein Tokenisiertes
Zertifikat direkt vom Erzeuger erstellt werden.
Die Zertifikate werden
dann direkt in der Blockchain gespeichert,
so dass die Daten nicht mehr verändert werden können.
Die Herkunft der erzeugten Energie ist so garantiert.
Governance Token ist eine bestimmte Art von Token,
die von bestimmten Unternehmen, häufig Tech Unternehmen
oder auch sogenannten decentralized
Organizations emittiert werden.
Die Governance Token haben bestimmte Rechte im Grunde.
Aus einer technischen Sicht sind sie häufig
sogenannte ERC 20 Token, das heißt, sie folgen dem Standart,
den auch viele andere Token Arten verwenden.
Aber das Recht, was der Besitzer dieses Governance
Tokens hat,
das unterscheidet sich vielleicht zum Beispiel
von Wertpapier Token.
Die Governance Token verbriefen Stimmrechte,
und die werden von Unternehmen herausgegeben.
Und wenn das Unternehmen etwas ändern möchte,
wenn es technische Änderungen
zum Beispiel implementieren möchte,
dann habe ich ein Stimmrecht, wenn ich
Stücke dieser Governance Token halte.
Das bedeutet, ich habe nicht nur einen monetären
Anreiz, diesen Token zu halten
und hoffe vielleicht auf einen zukünftigen Gewinn, sondern
ich habe auch ein Mitbestimmungsrecht
und ich kann mich in Communities engagieren
und meine Stimme wird gehört.
Anhand der Anzahl der Tokens, die ich halte.
Die große Herausforderung besteht
nun darin, wie die Verbraucher, seien es Geschäftskunden
oder sogar normale Einzelhandels Kunden,
zertifizierte erneuerbare Energiequellen erwerben können.
Und hier kann die Blockchain einen enormen Vorteil bieten.
Die Vision ist, dass man eines Tages in der Lage sein wird,
Zertifikate zum Zeitpunkt der Produktion
mit dem Verbrauch zum Zeitpunkt
des tatsächlichen Bedarfs abzugleichen.
Durch die Token
werden Windparks oder andere erneuerbare Energiequellen
für Kapitalanleger viel einfacher zugänglich.
Per Token in einen Solarpark zu investieren,
wird naher Zukunft ein etabliertes Verfahren sein.
Gleiches gilt für den Kauf von Strom
aus verschiedenen Energiequellen.
Im Bereich der Solarenergie
haben die ersten Energieversorger
ihre Anlagen bereits Tokenisiert.
Auch bei den Windkraftanlagen gibt es Plattformen,
die Betreiber der Anlagen mit Unternehmen
und Privatpersonen zusammenbringen.
Durch die Tokenisierung werden
die Eigentümer der Token zu Miteigentümer
an einer Windkraftanlage.
Durch den Verkauf des Stroms
erwirtschaften sie eine anteilige Rendite.
Aber auch die Betreiber der Anlagen profitieren.
Für sie ist die Tokenisierung eine weitere Möglichkeit,
um das Kapital der Anlage direkt einzusammeln.
Sie erhalten dadurch Reichweite
und Zugang zu hoher Liquidität.
Doch bislang
wird Energie noch überwiegend zentral verwaltet.
Bis die neue Technologie sich durchsetzt,
ist es noch ein weiter Weg.
Der nächste große Schritt ist
nun die Anbindung von Nachbarschaften.
Genauso wie bei größeren Projekten für erneuerbare Energien
werden nun ganze Gemeinden im Austausch für die Erlaubnis
zur Errichtung eines Solar oder Windparks
an der Nutzung der erzeugten Energie beteiligt.
Und dies wird Gemeinschaften
schaffen, die in der Lage sein werden,
Energie untereinander auszutauschen und zu handeln.
Wir sind also bereits auf dem richtigen Weg.
Ich denke, dass Deutschland wahrscheinlich
der größte Markt für Solar Anlagen in Europa ist.
Deutschland hat in dieser Hinsicht meisten Installationen,
aber man sieht diesen Trend auch in Frankreich.
Dort gibt es eine sehr strenge Regulierung
wie auch im Vereinigten Königreich und Italien.
Dies ist ein gesamteuropäischer Trend.
Die Rufe nach Nachhaltigkeit,
Menschenrechten oder Tierschutz
werden seit Jahren hörbar lauter.
Die Gesellschaft fordert zunehmend Produkte,
deren Entstehung transparent nachweisbar ist.
Die Tokenisierung der Lieferkette
steht für eine glaubwürdige Zukunft der Produkt Transparenz.
Spannend wird die Technologie im Hinblick auf das neu
verabschiedete Lieferketten Sorgfaltspflichten Gesetz.
Es soll belegen, dass menschenrechtliche und Umwelt
bezogene Sorgfaltspflichten nicht verletzt wurden.
Unternehmen werden verpflichtet,
jeden Schritt der Lieferkette
für Behörden und Verbraucher zu dokumentieren.
Nachhaltigkeit soll dadurch nachvollziehbar,
überprüfbar und sichtbar werden.
Die Tokenisierung macht
die Nachverfolgung eines Produktes
entlang der gesamten Wertschöpfungskette möglich.
Über ein handelsübliches Smartphone werden alle relevanten
Informationen zu einem Produkt gesammelt
und in einem Token gespeichert.
Dies geschieht von allen Standorten der Welt aus.
Ohne technisches Vorwissen der Mitarbeitenden per App
kann jede Art von Information gespeichert werden.
Jeder Produktionsschritte und jeder Rohstoff
innerhalb der Lieferkette sind
so jederzeit zuverlässig abrufbar.
So werden globale Lieferketten lückenlos nachvollziehbar.
Während bei dieser Berichterstattung eine auf der Blockchain
Technologie basierende Lieferkette
für eine lückenlose Dokumentation sorgen kann,
kann künstliche Intelligenz dabei helfen,
eine entsprechende Risikoanalyse durchzuführen.
So kann die KI beispielsweise Verträge mit Lieferanten
auf Menschenrechte und Umweltstandards analysieren.
Das ermöglicht dem Unternehmen gegebenenfalls
eine schnelle Anpassung der vertraglichen Regelungen
mit dem Zulieferer.
In der Landwirtschaft
ermöglicht die Tokenisierung es den Landwirten,
ihre Produkte in Token umzuwandeln.
Dadurch können internationale Investoren
in regionale Agrarrohstoffe investieren.
Im Gesundheitssektor hilft die Tokenisierung
medizinischen Institutionen bei der Nutzung
sensibler Daten von Patienten und Gesundheits
organisationen.
Die Logistikbranche arbeitet derzeit ebenfalls
an einem Konzept der Tokenisierung.
Hier soll der Frachtbrief in die Blockchain überführt werden
und so ein Problem der Verwaltung lösen.
Wenn die Organisierung Teil des zugrunde liegenden
Prozesses für Finanz Transaktionen wird,
können wir davon ausgehen,
dass die Gesamtgröße des Marktes größer sein wird
als das gesamte heutige Marktvolumen für Finanzanlagen.
Das wird natürlich nicht über Nacht passieren.
Dies wird in mehreren Schritten geschehen,
abhängig von Regulierung,
Innovation und allgemeiner Akzeptanz.
Wir brauchen demokratische Diskussionsprozesse.
Wir brauchen ein Management.
Es könnte durchaus noch 5 bis 20 Jahre dauern.
Es wird aber Schritt für Schritt
ein Wachstum des Marktes zu sehen sein.
Trotz der vielen Vorteile und ihrer zunehmenden Verbreitung
hat die Blockchain basierte
Tokenisierung von Vermögenswerten
auch ihre Grenzen.
Ein Nachteil, den es heute generell bei Token noch gibt,
ist die Skalierbarkeit der zugrundeliegenden Blockchains.
Wenn man heute das gesamte Wertpapier
Geschäft, was es weltweit gibt,
auf eine Blockchain bringen wollte,
um alle Wertpapiere zu Tokenisieren,
dann würden die Blockchains das Transaktions Volumen,
was dort abgewickelt nicht abbilden können.
Das bedeutet,
das System wäre einfach überlastet und überfordert.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich einer der Nachteile von Tokens.
Also die sind gar nicht in einem technischen Token
Standard enthalten,
sondern eher in den zugrunde liegenden Plattformen,
nämlich den Blockchains, auf denen diese Tokens existieren.
Es besteht ein Risiko, dass
Hacker auf die digitalen Vermögenswerte zugreifen
und diese stehlen.
Die Blockchain Technologie selbst gilt als sehr sicher.
Trotzdem gab es Fälle von erfolgreichen Hackerangriffen
auf Krypto Börsen und andere Blockchain basierte Systeme.
Die Angreifer verschafften sich den Zugang in der Regel
nicht über die Blockchain selbst, sondern über die Punkte,
an denen die Blockchain angeschlossen ist.
Es besteht daher die Notwendigkeit,
ein umfassendes und zuverlässiges System
zum Schutz vor Cyberkriminalität zu entwickeln.
Wenn man sich die globalen Regulierungen
als Wasserfall vorstellt,
dann würde ich sagen, dass Europa
an der Spitze dieses Wasserfalls steht.
Und ich denke, dass vieles von dem,
was wir mit Mica in Europa erreicht haben,
jetzt in die regulatorischen Überlegungen
anderer Staaten und Rechtsordnungen einfließt.
Banken haben seit jeher
die Rolle des Verwalters von Vermögenswerten.
Sie versuchen, ihren Aktionsradius zu erweitern
und den Kunden
ein möglichst breites
Spektrum an Dienstleistungen anzubieten.
Daher haben sie bereits begonnen,
die Tokenisierung von Vermögenswerten zu untersuchen.
Es könnten Banken sein, die in Zukunft die Emissionen
und den Handel von Tokenisierten Vermögenswerten verwalten.
Fintech hat sich in den letzten Jahren zu
einer der am schnellsten wachsenden Branchen entwickelt.
Also ein Bereich, in dem Moment
sehr, sehr viel Innovation bei Token stattfindet,
ist die sogenannte Zahlungsabwicklung.
Da kann man auch die Wertpapier Token als Beispiel nehmen.
Eine Anleihe beispielsweise zahlt einen regelmäßigen Coupon
vielleicht einmal pro Jahr einen bestimmten Zins an
diejenigen, die diese Anleihe halten.
Man kann den Token mit so viel Informationen ausstatten,
dass er die Höhe des Zinssatzes kennt
und den Emittenten den Zins Betrag automatisch einzieht
und dann an die Investoren automatisch verteilt.
In der traditionellen Welt
der Bankenwelt gibt es dafür die sogenannte Zahlstelle.
Also wenn ein Unternehmen eine Anleihe emittiert,
dann gibt es eine Bank,
die wird als Zahlstelle bestimmt und die sorgt dann dafür,
dass der Emittent rechtzeitig seinen Zins zahlt
und schüttet diesen an die Investoren aus.
Und das kann man eben durch Programmcode, auch durch
sogenannte Smart Contracts, automatisieren
und diese Informationen dem Token mitgeben.
Über die ökologischen Auswirkungen von Blockchain zu sprechen,
halte ich für sehr wichtig.
Aber wir als Branche müssen uns fragen,
was richtig und was falsch läuft.
Viele, die das Ganze von außen betrachten, denken,
dass hierfür der gleiche Energiemix verbraucht
wird, den wir täglich brauchen.
Und so sehr das auch der Fall war.
Es hat sich radikal geändert.
Nun werden eine Menge regenerativer Energien
zur Erzeugung der Nodes einer Blockchain genutzt,
wie Wasserkraft, Windenergie, aber auch Solarenergie.
Und das ist Energie, die aus der Sicht des Verbrauchers
bisher wenig genutzt wurde.
Sie konkurriert also nicht mit der Energie,
die Sie und ich in unserem täglichen Leben verwenden.
Mehr Als 60% der Energie,
die das Bitcoin Netzwerk verbraucht, ist bereits regenerativ
und an den anderen 40% müssen wir noch arbeiten.
Speziell die Finanzierung über Token hat die Chance,
die Weltwirtschaft in Zukunft drastisch zu verändern.
Unternehmen werden reale Vermögenswerte online
abbilden und dezentral finanzieren können.
Bestehende Finanzdienstleistungen
werden durch dezentrale Lösungen ersetzt.
Ich denke, in Zukunft werden wir wahrscheinlich im Bereich
Kryptowährungen eine Vielfalt
von verschiedenen digitalen Währungen sehen.
Es wird Stable Commons, Commercial Bank, Money Token
und auch verschiedene Arten von CBDCs geben.
Das Angebot wird vielfältig sein
oder wie man in Deutschland sagt, ein bunter Mix.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass der eine unbedingt
den anderen verdrängen wird.
Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich,
dass auch ein großes Interesse an Kryptowährungen besteht.
Etwa 23% der Europäer besitzen Kryptowährungen,
zumindest der Durchschnitt liegt bei 17%.
Wir liegen also noch unter dem globalen Durchschnitt.
Aber es wächst.
Wenn also die Menschen kein Vertrauen
in das bisherige System
haben, suchen sie nach Alternativen.
Und ich glaube, das ist aus politischer Sicht
eine Herausforderung für Regierungen.
Wie schaffen wir Vertrauen in unsere Systeme?
Im Zeitalter der digitalen Transformation?
Darauf gibt es keine einfache Antwort
und ich glaube,
gleichzeitig ist es vielleicht ein bisschen naiv zu glauben,
dass Kryptowährungen alle Probleme der Welt lösen können.
Ich möchte sagen,
hier brauchen wir eine Art gemäßigten
oder maßgeschneiderten Optimismus.
Es fehlt derzeit
noch an einer Standardisierung der Netzwerke.
Zudem müssen rechtliche Standards entwickelt werden,
um Unternehmen und Investoren gleichermaßen
Klarheit und damit Sicherheit zu verschaffen.
Die Auswirkungen auf unsere Gesellschaft
können wir bereits heute erkennen.
Die Technologie ist bereits im Hier und Jetzt angekommen.